such good news we found the other two
Oscars
somebody bought these coming off the
Santa Monica freeway on an off-ramp
$3.99 this is a bargain
oh no hernia
you know Rodgers and Hammerstein's said
there's nothing like a dame
I think Sinatra said that too didn't he
probably did and they are right here is
Oscars name ladies and gentlemen last
year's Best Supporting Actress Dame Judi
Dench
this year's nominees for the Best
Supporting Actor cover a wide range from
relative newcomer to huge star and from
a small boy to a man who's downright
huge he robbed nominee Michael Caine in
The Cider House Rules
Tom Cruise in magna
Duggal
in the talented mr. Ripley
Haley Joel Osment
The Sixth Sense
and the Oscar goes to Michael Caine
this is my cocaine second Academy Award
you want an aspirin 98
smooth and educating reader
thank you I was looking watching all the
others and thinking back when I I saw
the performances and you are thinking of
how the Academy changed the winner is to
the Oscar goes to and if ever there was
a category where the Oscar goes to
someone without there being a winner
it's this one because I do not feel like
being winner
you have Michael who I'd never heard of
quite frankly who is astonishing
you have Jude who's going to be a big
star no matter what happens
you have Tom who if you had won this
your pipe price would have gone down so
fast hey have you any idea what
supporting actors get paid
and we only get one motorhome small one
and Hallie Osmond what an astonishing
Darius
when I saw you I thought well that's me
out of it
so really I'm basically up here guys to
represent you as what I hope you will
all be a survivor
I want to I've got to hurry up or like
dick I wasn't here last time so give me
a bit with my speech the last time I won
so give me a bit extra time okay I want
to thank Harvey and Bob Weinstein the
milk poster at Miramax Lasser house drum
and extraordinary director and Richard
Gladstein
the wonderful actors I work with Tobey
Maguire Charlize Theron Jane Alexander
Kathy Baker all people who inhabit
rather than act and the wonderful
children that I acted were their last of
all I want to thank my two daughters
Dominique and Natasha and my wife